when the war broke out in 1939 again
there was the Continental power of Italy
and Germany and their Eastern European
allies along with the collusion of the
Soviet Union under the Molotov
Ribbentrop pact but the United States
was 3,000 miles distant in the Atlantic
from the theatres in Europe and even
more so in the Pacific from what was
going on in Southeast Asia and China and
so the question was if you're an axis
power and you have declared war on the
United States as happened in December of
1941 how do you reach it if you don't
have four-engine bombers that can bomb
the mainland do you have a mechanism to
send a ship over that can either what
bombard the shore well that could at
best that could be 20 miles but do you
have an aircraft carrier that can send
bombers they hit Detroit again the
answer is no so in the case of relative
naval strength the war breaks out with
some pretty stark realities number one
Italy which has the largest Navy after
the collapse of the French Navy in the
Mediterranean it has the largest Navy in
the Mediterranean does not build a
single aircraft carrier Germany does not
build a single aircraft carrier
it's almost analogous to their failure
to achieve a four-engine bomber program
in other words they do not have a
mechanism to transmit naval power in a
way that would hurt the mainland and the
industrial center of their enemies in
the United States or Russia or along
Russian Russia's coast or Great Britain
in contrast the United States starts the
war with six aircraft carriers fleet
carriers that is larger or almost as
large as 20,000 tons of displacement and
above and Britain has about seven and
more importantly there's been a
revolutionary change in thinking about
naval power before the war starts that
will see the United States create or
for more aircraft carriers than all of
the Navy's combined in world war ii and
britain has the same change of thinking
at least on the drawing boards when the
war breaks out now
the axis have some advantages unlike air
power they haven't quite made the same
catastrophic mistakes they are captives
to interwar naval thinking which puts a
great premise e on the battleship
according to the naval theories of the
great strategist Alfred Mahan the idea
was that if you could destroy the
enemy's warships at sea then like a wolf
among sheep you could send a dreadnought
or a battleship through an enemy convoy
and just be unstoppable in your
destruction you could just fire salvo
after salvo and nothing could stop you